ocurrieron en la madrugada como bien
decías la policía israelí entró en la
mezquita de galaxia aquí en Jerusalén
para desalojar a fieles que se habían
quedado para intentar pasar la noche Hay
que precisar que esto Solo lo pueden
hacer los últimos 10 días del ramadán no
obstante lo descrito por testigos y lo
que se ha visto en vídeos es una
violenta redada en la que la policía ha
utilizado bombas aturdidoras y gases
lacrimógenos y ha pegado a los fieles
que estaban en el lugar con bastones y
también culatas de las armas la policía
ha defendido su versión que es que se
vio forzada dice a intervenir porque un
grupo de jóvenes palestinos enmascarados
empezó a entonar cánticos y también
empezó a lanzar fuegos de artificios
artificiales y algunas piedras por esto
ha detenido a más de 400 personas y hay
una decena de heridos según la Cruz Roja
Palestina algunos por balas de goma y en
el pasado evidentemente todo un hecho
como este ha desencanado todo tipo de
escaladas graves como la de y uno esto
ya ha tenido una respuesta verbal como
bien comentabas tanto la autoridad
Palestina como Jordania Qatar Arabia
Saudita han condenado lo ocurrido esta
línea roja como denominan mientras que
también ha ocurrido Pues esa respuesta
física que Suele suceder y es que ha
habido tres intercambios de proyectiles
entre Israel y milicias de gaza y Yanira
hoy además inicia la Pascua judía que va
a coincidir con el ramadán y la Pascua
cristiana Cómo ha estado en función de
cómo ha estado la situación digamos
estos días cómo se espera que siga
Aunque Hoy es el primer incidente de
peso de mayor gravedad desde el inicio
del ramadán hay que enmarcarlo en un año
de 2023 con un inicio muy violento con
una cifra disparada de Muertos 95
palestinos muertos por fuego israelí y
sin ir más lejos el pasado sábado
primero de abril la policía israelí mató
a un joven palestino que también tenía
ciudadanía israelí Esto ocurrió cerca de
alaxa muy muy cerca de la mezquita Donde
ha ocurrido hoy el incidente y
evidentemente como tú mencionabas estas
festividades causan que se ponga de
nuevo en el centro esa disputa por el
control de recintos que es sagrado tanto
por musulmanes como por judíos en
concreto con motivo de la Pascua judía
hay muchos extremistas judíos que están
llamando a entrar y evidentemente eso se
está viendo como una provocación